it's it's really really neat really um
impressive uh you know and eve
as i say that the place sort of you know
you can almost feel that the ghosts or
whatever of of schrodinger piercing the
halls and those little anecdotes about
how he left his bike outside it's um
it's really nice to be here
so we are in trinity college dublin and
one of the more famous lecture theaters
in trinity college which is called the
schrodinger theater so you can tell from
my accent i'm irish i spent a lot of
time in dublin it's great to be back
here i didn't do my degree here i did my
degree in a rival institute um further
north uh on the north side of dublin but
um trinity college is the oldest
university in ireland it's uh was
founded at 1590 something 1591 92
something like that
by queen elizabeth the first
um it's reeks of history it reeks of
oh the various prestigious people that
have sort of walked these hallowed halls
it's um it's a nice feeling to be in in
this this lecture theater i lectured
here once before
back in 2003 but i actually didn't
remember that until i walked back in
again
it's called the schrodinger theater and
you might think that's really quite
strange why is it called the schrodinger
theater schrodinger was an irish he was
it was austrian what was the link with
with with shouldering in ireland
actually the first t-shock of ireland
somebody called eamon devalera invited
the first what t-shock what's that so
the first effective prime minister of
ireland
uh
invited uh schrodinger spent a lot of
time and effort actually get getting
schrodinger here devalera unlike most of
our politicians now was a very very keen
amateur mathematician and was very very
fascinated with what schrodinger was
doing in terms of quantum mechanics very
keen to get him over here to form what
was called the dublin institute of
advanced studies which still exists
while he was in dublin at the institute
for advanced studies schrodinger gave a
number of lectures both public lectures
and also lectures to undergraduates and
what he's really famous for
are a series of public lectures on on
the topic of what is life
it's called the schrodinger theater
because of schrodinger's close ties with
dublin because of showing his love of
the place he spent close to 20 years
here
not in trinity itself but in the dublin
institute for advanced studies but he
had very close ties with with trinity he
was a very strong lecturer very um
drew huge crowds for the time they had
to run them twice sometimes because
demand was so so strong course
schrodinger was a huge name so he he
attracted very very high profile
scientists and devalera was keen to
bring in those scientists and run
various different workshops and
conferences and meetings and um so this
theater as i understand it has been
around since about 1905
and very many um famous scientists just
not least with schrodinger but also
people like walton have have have
lectured in here
to to generations of students
schrodinger is one of the fathers of
quantum mechanics you'll have heard his
name um schrodinger's cat of course uh
which is i guess is the most famous and
um paradoxical thought experiment that
that there is
so schrodinger is is really revered in
terms of his knowledge of quantum
mechanics and his contributions of
course to quantum mechanics and he set
the foundations iggy mcgovern who's a
professor here told us that
the security guard who worked who
patrolled the grounds here used to get
very very very irrated schrodinger
because schrodinger would keep bringing
his bike in and leaving it in the in the
hallway and he'd continually have to
rebuke him for this so he didn't really
um stand on any sort of convention given
of course the schrodinger was a nobel
prize winner that didn't um influence
his ability to berate him at all
this is a classic this really is a
classic and i actually read over the
last couple of days i knew we were
coming to i was coming to dublin with
brady
and i i read this again i've got to
point out that actually it's not my book
i saw it on the shelves of our school
manager uh somebody called glenn archer
and i said oh i remember reading that as
a student a long long time ago would you
mind if i borrowed it very embarrassed
to say that was two years ago and i
still haven't given it back to him but
i'm glad i held on to it
this book is based on a series of
lectures to a large extent it's a
transcript of those lectures it's called
what is life physical aspect of the
living cell and that's perhaps already
surprising for those physicists among
you or those people among you who are
familiar with schrodinger's name in
terms of quantum mechanics you might
think well that's biology what's he
doing walking around with that as you
can see it's based on lectures delivered
under the arts process of the dublin
institute for advanced studies at
trinity college dublin in february 1943.
now there's some debate some people
think it was actually in this lecture
theater others argue that given that the
estimates of the numbers in the lecture
theater of order 400 if you look around
you're not going to get 400 people in
here so it's possible it wasn't here but
let's schrodinger are certainly lectured
in here like so many nobel laureates
after they get the nobel prize they
start thinking about the wider picture
and the broader things and really
thinking about the very deep questions
schrodinger was fascinated by what is
life um where does life come from and
you know
sort of our equilibrium state for
physicist the equilibrium state of me
and brady is death that's when we're at
equilibrium and we're held out of
equilibrium and how are we held out of
equilibrium and we're obviously some
degree of ordered structure and
how do we turn all this entropy and
disorder around us so this was a huge
huge influence on so many
biologists biochemists who was
struggling to try and understand um
the the nature of how of hereditary um
factors the nature of genes the nature
of chromosomes how genetic information
was trans transferred and schrodinger
was actually i think these ideas he was
building obviously on other ideas and
there's nothing really new in here but
what he did is he brought all those
different streams together and um
couched it in physical terms and couched
it in a way i think well
imagine that biologists and biochemists
weren't really thinking of at the time
and he was a huge huge influence on
watson and crick and they've admitted
that in terms of their um discovery of
dna and under their their work in dna in
terms of
how genetic information is passed from
generation to generation
they're meant to be squares
perfectly periodic
imagine they're just floor tiles you
just lay them out
boring absolutely zero information
content well not quite in zero
information content but a very very low
information content low entropy
low um
interest value or low interest level
because all you need to know is right
i've got a block and all i want to do is
repeat that and you know exactly how far
i have to go in this direction in this
direction to reproduce the whole thing
schrodinger was saying was how could we
have all this complexity of life because
at the time solid-state physics and it's
true even to this day
undergraduate people who do degrees in
physics
focus
on perfectly periodic crystals that's
the majority of our time is spent on
these type of things and it's very
important because a lot of the
properties of matter depend on those
periodic crystals but from the point of
view of complexity from the point of
view of information content this is
really really dull and what schrodinger
was saying is well we need something
that's a periodic something that's it's
a great shame we can't um go to the
brick of kells i don't think we're
allowed to film the brookie cats but
when we look at the book of kells that
is so rich it's completely the opposite
of this completely a periodic but it has
such content such info such rich
information contact and schrodinger
realized that's really what we needed
was that ear periodicity and then when
watson and crick came along what's
really really um
actually gobsmacking is that well it's
the the the aperiodicity is not in the
the atomic structure itself it's in how
you pair up the base pairs how you pair
up the adenine guanine thymine cytosine
and how they link together and that's
the where the aperiodicity comes in so
ten years before watson and crick made
the discoveries ten years before they
did the crystallography that got the
structure of dna that wonderful double
helix structure that you're so um used
to seeing crop ups is right across all
the the imagery and science
schrodinger was preempting this got to
stress again that in that book there's
nothing really new but for a physicist
to read that and again it was two years
since i last read and i came back to it
and you can read it it's a very
quick book to read it doesn't you know
take a long large amount of time it's
written in a very very elegant style and
i think it was that elegance and that
ability to put the ideas across
so simply and so with such impact that
really had such an influence on so many
other scientists both in physics and
outside of physics